This is evolving into an actual disaster at this point. I think I got it. I think I got it. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 100, recorded on October 16th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about a ton of things. Programming language logos, code formatting, Bryce's upcoming trip to O3DCon, and so much more. What programming language has the best logo in your opinion? Ooh, great question. Great question.
这简直要变成一场真正的灾难了。我想我搞定了。我想我搞定了。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 100 期，录制于 2022 年 10 月 16 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论大量话题。编程语言徽标、代码格式化、布莱斯即将到来的 O3DCon 之旅等等。你认为哪个编程语言拥有最好的徽标？哦，好问题。好问题。
To start off, what are we starting off here, Bryce? What are we starting off? We're starting off with great question. Great question. To start off, what are we starting off here, Bryce? What are we starting off? We're starting off with my question. Bryce probably doesn't even know the significance of today's recording. It is episode... Number 100, right? Number 100, which technically... I did know that.
首先，我们从哪里开始，布莱斯？我们要从哪里开始？我们从好问题开始。好问题。首先，我们从哪里开始，布莱斯？我们要从哪里开始？我们从我的问题开始。布莱斯可能甚至不知道今天录音的重大意义。这是第... 第 100 期，对吧？第 100 期，从技术上讲... 我其实知道。
I did know that. I knew we were getting close. I wasn't sure if it was going to be this time or the next time, but I knew we were coming up on it. So we've got some special things planned for today. First things first, what is the best? So technically, what is the best programming logo? I'm going to take my mic and zoom out into the background here off screen so we can see all of them.
我其实知道。我知道我们快到了。我不确定是这一次还是下一次，但我知道我们要迎来了。所以我们为今天计划了一些特别的事情。首先，什么是最好的？从技术上讲，什么是最好的编程徽标？我要把我的麦克风拿起来，拉远镜头，对准背景这里屏幕外的地方，这样我们就能看到所有的徽标了。
So what do we have? Actually, let's go through them all first. We're just going to list them all off. D, Ruby, Scala, Swift, Lisp, Racket, Java, Basic, OCaml, the Dialog APL logo, Kotlin, which technically is out of date. Kotlin used to have like a blue, purple, orange one. Now it's just this like single color, no multiple triangles, single color, purple, pink. I actually like it better.
那么我们有什么？实际上，让我们先把它们全部过一遍。我们只把它们一一列出来。D、Ruby、Scala、Swift、Lisp、Racket、Java、Basic、OCaml、Dialog APL 徽标，Kotlin（技术上讲它已经过时了。Kotlin 以前有那种蓝、紫、橙相间的徽标。现在它只是这种单色，没有多个三角形，单色，紫色、粉色。我其实更喜欢现在的）。
So Kotlin's out of the running because it's no longer exists in this form. Lua, Pascal, Python, JavaScript, which is the yellow box. C++, Dart, TypeScript, J, F sharp, Clojure, Go, Smalltalk, which actually really Smalltalk doesn't have a logo. That's the cover of like the 1972 Byte Magazine or like that uh groovy elm c-sharp some people would debate that that's not the official c-sharp logo which the real one i think is a circle but it looks stupid so i use this one um elixir haskell php r algol rust erlang cobalt and seed what's your what do you think the best uh logo is here hmm i think off the top of my head the swift logo
所以 Kotlin 已经出局了，因为它不再以这种形式存在。Lua、Pascal、Python、JavaScript（也就是黄色方框）、C++、Dart、TypeScript、J、F#、Clojure、Go、Smalltalk（实际上 Smalltalk 真的没有徽标。那是 1972 年《Byte》杂志的封面，或者是那种...呃，炫酷的 Elm、C#，有些人可能会争辩说那不是官方的 C# 徽标，真正的徽标我记得是一个圆圈，但看起来太蠢了，所以我用了这个）嗯，Elixir、Haskell、PHP、R、Algol、Rust、Erlang、Cobol 和 C。你认为这里最好的徽标是什么？嗯，我想脱口而出的话，就是 Swift 徽标。
interesting interesting calls out to me why do you like that one the best I think that it's like most creative. You know, it's this little like bird that's swooping down and it captures like, you know, motion. And so it gives you a sense of, you know, motion or speed or swiftness. And, you know, that's obviously the name of the language. I think also that's one of the goals of the language. And I think I should explain.
有趣，有趣，它吸引了我。为什么你最喜欢那个？我觉得它最具创意。你知道，它就像一只俯冲而下的小鸟，捕捉到了那种...你知道，运动感。所以它给你一种...你知道，运动、速度或敏捷的感觉。显然，这也是这门语言的名字。我想这也是这门语言的目标之一。我想我应该解释一下。
I don't know anything about why they chose to call it Swift, but my impression of the language is that it's a language that's meant to be easy to use, fast to develop with, but also a language that is, you know, lets you write fast apps. And all that's captured, I think, by the logo. A lot of the other programming language logos are like, you know, the name of the thing with some form of fancy text or shape around it. And some of them are just like really just the name, not to bash on any, but Algo and Cobol, I'm kind of looking at you. Yeah, I mean, those are sort of stretches, Basic, Algo, Cobol, Cobol. I'll tell you, like, for my requirements, some of them immediately get ruled out as ones that I don't like.
我不知道他们为什么决定叫 Swift，但我对这门语言的印象是，它是一门易于使用、开发速度快，同时也能让你编写快速应用的语言。我认为，所有这些都在徽标中捕捉到了。许多其他编程语言的徽标就像是...你知道，名字周围加上某种花哨的文字或形状。其中一些真的就只是名字而已，无意贬低任何人，但 Algol 和 Cobol，我是在看着你们。是的，我的意思是，那些有点勉强，Basic、Algol、Cobol、Cobol。我告诉你，就我的要求而言，其中一些会立即被排除在外，因为我不喜欢它们。
Because one of the criteria, I don't have many criteria, but one of the criteria for logos is I want them to have the same dimensions and width and height. Because a lot of the times when you're trying to put, you know, five logos next to each other on a cover slide for a talk, I don't want to have to manually adjust that stuff. And when you have something that is either super narrow, like the Scala logo, or super wide and short, like the ones typed out like Basic and Algo, PHP fits into this category as well. Java also doesn't look super narrow, but it actually is because of the lettering underneath. Whenever you use those automatic sort of distribute by width to sort of align things nicely, those logos always mess it up. Whereas if you have nice sort of boxy logos, usually you can
因为其中一个标准（我没有太多标准），但徽标的标准之一是，我希望它们具有相同的尺寸、宽度和高度。因为很多时候，当你试图在演讲的封面幻灯片上把五个徽标并排放在一起时，我不想手动调整那些东西。而当你有一些超级窄的东西（比如 Scala 徽标），或者超级宽而矮的东西（比如像 Basic 和 Algol 那样打出来的字，PHP 也属于这一类。Java 看起来也不是超级窄，但实际上因为下面的字母，它确实很窄）。每当你使用那些按宽度自动排布来很好地对齐事物的功能时，这些徽标总是会把布局搞砸。而如果你有很好、方方正正的徽标，通常你可以
use that quite nicely. So Go also is a logo that is sort of very um wide and not very tall so my favorites and i i like ones that um are very polished so like swift fits into that category i think my personal favorites are the lisp logos not the one in the bottom corner um but the closure and racket logos those are very nice and i think actually the Clojure one was designed by the brother of Rich Hickey who created the language, which is kind of a neat story. I think actually C++, D, they all have great logos as well. Yeah, I kind of like the C++ logo. What's the logo that's on the second column bottom?
很好地利用它们。所以 Go 也是一个徽标，它非常...呃，很宽而且不够高。所以我的最爱是...我喜欢那些非常精致的徽标，比如 Swift 就属于那一类。我想我个人最喜欢的是 Lisp 徽标（不是底角那个），而是 Clojure 和 Racket 徽标，它们非常好看。而且实际上 Clojure 徽标是由创建该语言的里奇·希基（Rich Hickey）的兄弟设计的，这算是一个很酷的故事。实际上我认为 C++、D，它们的徽标也都很棒。是的，我有点喜欢 C++ 徽标。第二列底部那个是什么徽标？
That's the specific to a company Dialog Limited APL. You see, if you told me that with no contacts or just knowing what the C++ logo looks like, I would have thought that was the D. Yeah, this is out of date because we actually have a new Apple-like logo for APL in general. And one of the criteria, this is not actually what I think. What does Apple-like logo for APL in general. And one of the criteria, this is not actually what I think. What does Apple-like mean?
那是 APL 公司的特定 Dialog Limited APL 徽标。你看，如果你在没有任何背景信息的情况下告诉我，或者仅仅知道 C++ 徽标长什么样，我可能会认为那是 D 语言。是的，这已经过时了，因为我们实际上有一个全新的、类似于苹果风格的 APL 徽标。标准之一（这其实不是我的想法）。什么叫像苹果的 APL 徽标？苹果风格到底是什么意思？
Apple, so actually let's get it out. Let's get it out. And we promise we've got some other topics to get to, but let's, I'll actually, how should I do this? Should I just send you, I'll just send you a link. And we'll put this in the show notes for sure. I can open links. APL logo. And we'll put this in the show notes for sure. I can open links.
苹果，实际上让我们把它调出来。让我们把它调出来。我们保证还有其他话题要谈，但让我们...我实际上，我该怎么做？我只是发给你，我发你一个链接。我们肯定会把这个放在节目笔记中。我可以打开链接。APL 徽标。我们肯定会把这个放在节目笔记中。我可以打开链接。
APL logo. And we're just – Although I don't have my keyboard right now because I'm packing up and going to Austin for two weeks. Going to Austin? Yeah. Yeah, Austin, then the C++ committee meeting in Hawaii, and then the ISOJTC one committee meeting in Japan. Wait, I thought that was in February. No, that's in November. Oh, interesting, interesting.
APL 徽标。我们只是...虽然我现在没有键盘，因为我在收拾行李，要去奥斯汀待两周。要去奥斯汀？对。对，奥斯汀，然后去夏威夷参加 C++ 委员会会议，接着去日本参加 ISO JTC 1 委员会会议。等等，我以为那是在二月？不，那是十一月。哦，有趣，有趣。
All right, we'll talk about that more in a sec. APL logo in the chat. Oh, I like this one. So why the Apple, though? So a lot of stuff in the APL community, there's a lot of apple puns because APL can sort of be pronounced apple. So there's a lot of like and I think historically going back to like conferences that were in the 70s and 80s, they would give out a lot of stickers and swag that had apples and like I heart APL in it because of the pronunciation. And so one of the criteria for I think lesser well known languages. So I actually
好吧，我们一会儿再详细谈这个。聊天框里的 APL 徽标。哦，我喜欢这个。不过，为什么是苹果？所以在 APL 社区中有很多东西，有很多关于苹果的双关语，因为 APL 的发音听起来有点像 apple（苹果）。所以有很多...而且我认为从历史来看，回到 70 年代和 80 年代的技术会议上，他们会发放很多带有苹果图案的贴纸和周边，里面还有我爱 APL（I heart APL）之类的，因为发音的缘故。因此，对于不太知名的语言来说，这是标准之一。所以我其实
like the Swift or not the Swift, the F sharp logo quite a bit, which is the little purple diamond. But for less well known languages, which is the term that I'm referring to for languages that some of them are esoteric, but some of them are not esoteric, but they're also not mainstream. And I think non-mainstream is a bad term. So I've started to use the phrase less well-known for languages that fit in that category, APL of which is definitely one. If you're going to create a logo, I think you inevitably have to put the name of your language because when people see the diamond that's blue, inevitably, and even Clojure, even though I like the Clojure logo,
挺喜欢 Swift 的（或者说不是 Swift，是 F# 的徽标，就是那个紫色的小菱形）。但是对于不太知名的语言（这是我用来指代其中一些语言是冷门的，但有些不是冷门，只是它们也不是主流。我认为“非主流”是个不好的词。所以我开始使用“不太知名”这个短语来指代符合这一类别的语言，APL 绝对就是其中之一）。如果你要创建一个徽标，我认为你不可避免地得写上你们语言的名字，因为当人们看到那个蓝色的菱形时，不可避免地，甚至连 Clojure（尽管我喜欢 Clojure 徽标），
everyone's like, what language is that? Because they don't know. Yeah, yeah. And you love to just use the logos in your slides. And this has been, I mean, I love how you make your slides, but this has been the one thing that I've mentioned to you, you love to just use the logos in your slides. And this has been, um, I mean, I love how you make your slides, but this has been the one thing that I've mentioned to you. I think, uh, once or twice in the past that sometimes I'm seeing your slides and I'm like, I don't know what that is because it doesn't have the, um, the name in it. Um, I think what
每个人都会问：“那是什么语言？”因为他们不认识。对，对。而你就是喜欢在幻灯片里直接使用徽标。这一直是...我的意思是，我喜欢你制作幻灯片的方式，但这曾是我向你提到过的一件事，你就是喜欢在幻灯片里直接使用徽标。这一直是...我的意思是，我喜欢你制作幻灯片的方式，但这曾是我过去向你提过一两次的一件事，有时候我看到你的幻灯片时会想：“我不知道那是什么”，因为它没有...呃，没有名字。呃，我想
Russ did too is like, even though Russ didn't put the name of it and it's gotten pretty popular, but like having an R or, or like some to indicate give like give them give someone who doesn't know like a shot at guessing is like that's that's a bare minimum I think um you know it's you know I was talking about logos or programming languages sounds a little um maybe superficial but this is things like logo and design and how we represent things is actually I think something that both you and I
Rust 做得也挺好，比如，尽管 Rust 没有写上名字，而且它已经变得相当受欢迎，但带有一个字母 R，或者某种暗示，给那些不认识的人一个猜中的机会，这是最低限度的要求，我认为...你知道，你知道的，我之前谈论徽标或编程语言听起来可能有点...也许有些表面化，但诸如徽标、设计以及我们如何呈现事物之类的事情，实际上我认为这是你和我
have a great interest in you know we've talked a few times in this show about how we both take great care in how we make our slides and how we present stuff and one thing that I think we both do that we appreciate greatly in each other's slide content is our, our use of diagrams and visual representations.
都非常感兴趣的领域。你知道，我们在节目中多次讨论过我们俩如何都非常注重制作幻灯片的方式以及如何展示内容。我认为我们俩都在彼此的幻灯片内容中非常欣赏的一点，就是我们对图表和视觉表现形式的大量使用。
You know, I almost, I almost as a rule, you know, if I'm making a slide, I try to think, how can I have this slide have like no text? And if it's a slide that just has text and if it's code, then, you know, that's one thing. But if it's a slide that's describing something, I want to have some, some diagram or some visual representation. And I think the reason for that is, for me, I feel like I can convey a lot more. But also I'm speaking. If I'm verbally saying something to you, I can say whatever I would put on the slide. And I would prefer to just say it. Maybe I write down a few of the important things in the slide, but I'd prefer to give you, you know, I have this other medium of communicating, like I'm already going to give you text just in the form of speech. Um, and so I'd like to be
你知道，我几乎...几乎就像一条铁律一样，你知道，如果我在制作幻灯片，我会试着去想：我怎样才能让这张幻灯片做到几乎没有文字？如果这是一张只有文字的幻灯片，如果是代码，那么，那是另一回事。但如果这是一张描述某些事物的幻灯片，我希望有一些图表或某种视觉表现形式。我想原因在于，对我来说，我觉得我能传达更多信息。而且我在说话。如果我正在口头对你讲某事，我可以把我本来会写在幻灯片上的任何内容说出来。我宁愿直接说出来。也许我会在幻灯片上写下一些重要的东西，但我更愿意给你...你知道，我有另一种沟通媒介，就像我已经通过演讲的形式给你提供文字一样。
able to give you some, some diagram or something, um, or some visual, um, uh, that represents things. And so I think that's why we, that's why we like logos. And that's, that's one of the reasons why you love to put the programming language logos in your talks, right? not just color and graphics and visualizations, but just like, you know, I've heard, you know, one of the things I sort of call out all the way up to keynote speakers and conferences is like not using a monospace font in their code examples, which just drives me nuts. And I'll have to finish reading this book before, maybe we should turn this into a whole other episode, but there's a book that I'm currently reading called Mind in Motion by Barbara Tversky, who is the wife of Amos Tversky, who anyone that's read sort of the behavioral cognitive science books that by
呃，所以我希望能给你提供一些图表之类的东西，呃，或者一些能够代表事物的视觉元素。所以我想这就是我们...这就是我们喜欢徽标的原因。这也是你喜欢在演讲中加入编程语言徽标的原因之一，对吧？不仅仅是颜色、图形和可视化，还有...你知道，我曾听说过，你知道，我甚至对主题演讲嘉宾和会议提出过的一点批评是，他们在代码示例中不使用等宽字体，这简直把我逼疯了。我得在读完这本书之前把它看完，也许我们应该把这变成另一整期节目，但我目前正在读一本书，叫《思维在路上》（Mind in Motion），作者是芭芭拉·特沃斯基（Barbara Tversky），她是阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）的妻子，任何读过...类行为认知科学书籍的人都会知道
Richard Thaler and Daniel Kahneman. One of the more famous ones is Nudge by I believe Richard Thaler and then also Thinking Fast and Thinking Slow by Daniel Kahneman. Kahneman and Tversky were these, a pair, I think Kahneman is still alive, but Amos Tversky passed away. But they're a pair of these cognitive psychologists, and they have written all these books about these sort of phenomenons of heuristics and how our brains are really good at, you know, making estimations and stuff, but at many times they fail us.
理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）和丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）写的书。其中比较著名的是理查德·塞勒写的《助推》（Nudge），还有丹尼尔·卡尼曼写的《思考，快与慢》（Thinking, Fast and Slow）。卡尼曼和特沃斯基是一对...我记得卡尼曼还活着，但阿莫斯·特沃斯基已经去世了。但他们是一对认知心理学家搭档，他们写了所有这些关于启发式现象以及我们的大脑如何非常擅长进行估计之类的东西的书，但在很多时候它们也会让我们失望。
And one of my, I don't think I've ever told this on the podcast, but in the book, Thinking Fast and Thinking Slow, which is amazing if you can get through it, but it's a tome, is this study they did where, I'm going to, we're going to go on a bajillion tangents right now, but it's a study where you take a bowl of cold water and you get people to place their hand in it for a minute. And it's uncomfortable
我不知道我是否在播客中说过这个，但在《思考，快与慢》这本书中（如果你能读完的话它非常棒，但它是一本皇皇巨著），有一个他们做过的研究（我要...我们现在要扯到十万八千里之外去了），这是一个这样的研究：你拿一碗冷水，让人们把手放进去一分钟。这很不舒服
but you say oh you know blah blah blah and then they ask people how you feel after that minute and then they take the same group of folks and whatever some of them do only one some of them do both some of them do the latter and the latter one is to do the exact same thing put your hand in a bowl of cold water and then they do that for 60 seconds and instead of ending it there they then increase the temperature just by a degree and then have them hold their hand in the water for 30 more seconds. And overwhelmingly,
但你会说“哦，你知道，巴拉巴拉巴拉”，然后他们会问人们那一分钟之后感觉如何。接着他们找来同一群人，无论其中一些人只做了一次，一些人做了两次，或者有人做了后一种情况。后一种情况是：做完全相同的事情——把手放进一碗冷水中，坚持 60 秒。但他们不是在那里结束，而是把水温仅仅调高一度，然后让他们把手在水中再多放 30 秒。结果绝大多数人
when they ask people at the end of that 90 seconds, which is 30 seconds more of discomfort, but it's slightly more comfortable than just the 60 seconds, people say that they actually prefer the 90 seconds one, even though overall, you're spending more time in discomfort. And this led to Daniel Kahneman terming this basically the peak end rule, which he said is basically that the way that people remember events is defined by sort of the highs and the lows, like the worst point or the best point, and the very last thing
在 90 秒结束时（这比不舒服的时间多出了 30 秒，但比仅仅 60 秒稍微舒服一点点）接受询问时，他们说自己其实更喜欢 90 秒的那次，尽管总体而言，你花在不舒服状态下的时间更长。这促使丹尼尔·卡尼曼将其创造性地命名为“峰终定律”（peak-end rule），他表示这基本上意味着人们对事件的记忆方式是由高潮和低谷（即最糟糕的点或最好的点）以及最后发生的事情所决定的。
that happened. So because their hand is finishing in like slightly warmer but still uncomfortable water, their view of the overall experience is better than the one that was shorter but ended in like colder water. And like the way that he parlays this into society is he's like, and this is kind of, you can see this show up when people say, you know, don't go to bed angry, you know, fighting with your significant other because you're going to remember that. Or if you go on some day trip or vacation, if the last thing that happens is like something negative, you kind of remember the whole thing as a negative experience, even if like the whole day was great and you just ended on this one bad note. Anyways, I just, I find stuff like that incredibly fascinating. Anyways, back to this
因此，由于他们的手最后泡在稍微暖和一点但仍然不舒服的水中，他们对整体体验的看法要好于那个时间较短但以更冷的水结束的体验。他将这一点引申到社会生活中，就像人们所说的那样：“不要带着愤怒上床睡觉，不要和你的另一半吵架，因为你会记住那一刻。”或者如果你去进行某次一日游或度假，如果最后发生的事情是负面的，你基本上会把整个经历都当作负面体验来记住，即使整 A 天都棒极了，只是以这样一个糟糕的音符结束。总之，我...我发现诸如此类的事情极其迷人。不管怎样，回到这本
book that I'm currently reading, Mind in Motion by Barbara Barbara Tversky, who's married to or was married to Amos Tversky. It's all about like the thesis of the book is that the foundation of thought is built upon visual thinking and visualizations as opposed to like Noam Chomsky's like the foundation of all thought is language. So it's like, you know, there's this one school of thought that thinks that all of our ability to think and come up with ideas and stuff is based on language at the bottom of this triangle languages at the bottom. And she's saying, no, no,
我目前正在读的书，芭芭拉·特沃斯基（Barbara Tversky）写的《思维在路上》（Mind in Motion），她嫁给了（或者曾嫁给）阿莫斯·特沃斯基。这本书的核心论点是，思考的基础建立在视觉思维和可视化之上，而不是像诺姆·乔姆斯基（Noam Chomsky）所说的那样——所有思考的基础是语言。所以就像...你知道，有一种思想学派认为，我们所有的思考能力和想出主意等能力都是基于语言的，语言在这个三角形的最底层。而她说：不，不，
no, absolutely not. It's based on like the ability to think and visual or not to think to visualize, um, with like structure and images. And, uh,
不，绝对不是。它是基于...思考和视觉化的能力，或者说不是思考，而是用结构和图像进行视觉化的能力。而且，
I think, I think I, I like wholeheartedly agree with this, this theory because there have been times where I've taken some like basic notes or whatever and then structured it into some kind of like Venn diagram or flow chart. And then immediately from like adding structure to some information, you make some observation that you wouldn't make otherwise if you were just sort of like taking notes or whatever. And I think this ties in and back to the code examples is that like when you get rid of the monospace fonts in code, your ability to like pattern match on certain things, like that's why I like in my code aligning. If you're assigning a bunch of, you know, the results of functions to variables X, Y,
我想...我想我...我全心全意地同意这个理论，因为有些时候，我做了一些基本的笔记之类的，然后把它组织成某种维恩图或流程图。然后通过向某些信息添加结构，你会立即做出一些观察，如果你只是随手记笔记之类的，你是绝对不会发现这些观察的。我认为这又回到了代码示例上，那就是当你在代码中去掉等宽字体时，你对某些东西进行模式匹配的能力...这就是为什么我喜欢在代码中进行对齐。如果你正在将一堆...你知道，函数的返回值赋值给变量 X、Y、
and Z, if those variables have different length variable names like a bb ccc i like lining up the equal sign so you can very clearly see the names of the variables on the left yeah i did the same thing and it's interesting because that that that particular thing um i very rarely see folks do that i know it's something that both you and i do yeah um it's a setting in clang format yeah yeah um uh but uh it's not it's it's something that that that uh you know it's sort of my career before clang format was a thing um i used to manually do you know i would manually well i manually do it but i used to whatever team i was working with they would always be like what are you doing like this is weird like don't do that yeah i've had people say that as well. Yeah. But, but it's, it's funny that that's
和 Z，如果这些变量具有不同长度的变量名字（比如 a、bb、ccc），我喜欢把等号对齐，这样你就能非常清楚地看到左边的变量名。是的，我也这样做。有趣的是，那个特定的事情...我很少看到有人这么做，我知道这是你和我都会做的一件事。是的，这是 clang format 中的一个设置。对，对...但是...这不是...这是那种...你知道的，在 clang format 出现之前的我的职业生涯里，我过去常常手动...你知道，我会手动...好吧，我确实是手动做的，但我过去常常...无论我和哪个团队合作，他们总是会问：“你在干什么？这太奇怪了...别这么做。”是的，我也遇到过别人这么说。对。但是，很有趣的是，那
something, something that we, we have a very similar sense of style when it comes to code formatting. Yeah. It irritates me like Python. I can't remember cause I don't use in my personal Python code black or pep eight, but I think both of them don't do that. And like, if you use it, it automatically you know shifts your equal signs to one space after the variable name and um yeah it just it doesn't make the variable names pop and it even like it affects the way that you name things because you kind of want all your variables to have you know roughly same length names because if you have everything that's like you know three to five characters and then one that says you know, roughly same length names, because if you have everything that's like, you know, three to five characters, and then one that says, you know, factory, you know, deprecator,
是我们对代码格式化有着非常相似的审美感。是的。这让我很恼火，就像 Python 一样。我不记得了，因为我在自己的个人 Python 代码中不用 Black 或 PEP 8，但我想它们都不做这件事。而且，如果你用了它，它会自动...你知道，把你的等号移到变量名后面一个空格的位置，并且...是的，它就是不会让变量名字突出显示。它甚至会影响你命名事物的方式，因为你某种程度上希望你所有的变量都有...你知道，大致相同长度的名字。因为如果你所有的名字都是...你知道，三到五个字符，然后有一个写着...你知道，factory、
blah, blah, blah, that's like 20 characters long, it then shoots all your equal signs out, you know, with you have a ton of space. Anyways, yeah, I think we should we should spend more time talking about this in another episode. One of my, I'm trying to find it one of my favorite uh uh logos that i've made for something um i i just over the years i have fallen into the role of being the um the unofficial designer yeah the unofficial graphic designer for a variety of things um but one of my favorites is the, is the cub logo, which I can't take that much credit for because the design is actually based on something from the cub documentation. Um, and it's, uh, this diagram, um, the one of the, like the web, right? With the letters.
deprecator，巴拉巴拉巴拉，长达 20 个字符，它就会把你的所有等号一下子顶出去，你知道的，留下了大量的空白。不管怎样，是的，我想我们应该...我们应该花更多时间在另一期节目中讨论这个。我最喜欢的...我正在努力寻找它...我为某样东西制作的自己最喜欢的徽标之一...多年来，我不知不觉地扮演了...呃，非官方设计师的角色，是的，我是各种事物的非官方平面设计师...但我最喜欢的之一，是那个 cub 徽标，我其实不能居功至伟，因为这个设计实际上是基于 cub 文档中的某个东西。而且，它是...这个图表，呃，就像网络一样的那个，对吧？带有字母的那个。
Yeah. It's just like this little like web that shows, um, uh, it that shows a series of lines and then dots, and there's dots in the lines. There's like eight lines that are in parallel, and there's dots, and it shows how a parallel reduction works. And then there's lines, there's those primary lines, and then there's connections between those lines, between the different dots, showing the values from these two threads are reduced into one, and then there's connections between those lines, between the different dots showing, you know, these,
是的。它就像这个微小的网络，展示了一系列线条，然后还有点，线上面有点。大概有八条平行的线，上面有点，它展示了并行约减（reduction）是如何工作的。然后还有线，那些主要的线，然后这些线之间、不同的点之间有连接，展示了来自这两个线程的值是如何约减为一个的，然后这些线之间、不同的点之间还有连接，展示了，你知道，这些，
the values from these two threads are reduced into one and then et cetera, et cetera, they all get combined together. And I can't remember if the diagram that we use for the logo is the one from, from a scanner or from a reduction. But I, I saw that in the, the comp docs and I'm like, you know, we, we haven't had a logo for Cub we really need one and Cub
来自这两个线程的值被约减为一个，以此类推，它们全都组合在了一起。我记不清我们用作标志（logo）的那个图表是从扫描器来的还是从约减操作来的。不过我，我在...编译文档中看到了那个，我想，你知道的，我们，我们一直没有为 Cub 做一个 logo，我们真的很需要一个，而 Cub
is this you know parallel algorithms primitives library and I was like this is just the perfect thing and I made a sort of stylized version of it and I've been very happy with it and you know
就是这个，你知道的，并行算法原语库，当时我就觉得这简直是太完美了，于是我做了一个它的简化风格版本，而且我对它非常满意，你知道的，
some people might think like know it's some people might think like oh it's so silly for libraries to have logos but like it's no it's false like it's just i i'm sure there's some study that has either been done or that could be done that would prove that people are easy are able to build like connections and remember things better for companies if they have some really memorable logo. The same way that more people know what Amazon is than know who Jeff Bezos is. Don't get me wrong. Bezos is a famous guy. But I'm sure there's a ton of places in the world where if you ask someone who Bezos is, they wouldn't know.
有些人可能会觉得，哦，库拥有 logo 这事太傻了。但其实不是，这不对，我相信一定有过某种研究，或者可以做某种研究来证明，如果公司有一个非常让人印象深刻的 logo，人们更容易建立联系并更好地记住它们。就像更多人知道亚马逊是谁，而不是知道杰夫·贝佐斯是谁一样。别误会我。贝佐斯是个大人物。但我敢肯定，世界上有很多地方，如果你问别人贝佐斯是谁，他们根本不知道。
But if you ask them what Amazon was, they definitely would know. I think the same can be said about logos. Like if you were to ask folks, you know, what the golden arches are. Yeah, that's probably close though, because I'm sure everyone knows what McDonald's is as well. But I'm sure there's examples where like logos are more like recognizable than the names of companies. Yeah, the maybe the Nike Swish. Oh, yeah, yeah. Although it's kind of hard because at that level, almost everyone knows the companies as well. But like NumPy, which is a Python library,
但如果你问他们亚马逊是什么，他们绝对知道。我觉得关于 logo 也是一样的道理。比如如果你问大家，你知道金色拱门是什么吗？好吧，这可能不太贴切，因为我确信每个人也都知道麦当劳是什么。但我确信有些例子中，logo 比公司名称更具辨识度。对，也许是耐克的钩子标志。哦，对，对。尽管这有点难，因为在这个级别上，几乎每个人也都知道这些公司。不过比如 NumPy，这是一个 Python 库，
it's got a fantastic logo, and it sort of builds the fact of matrices into it. And yeah, I think, you know, it's a... I saw, was it on some subreddit, that people were whining and asking about the fact that Carbon didn't have, or maybe that came up in the last interview with Sean Baxter, that Carbon doesn't have a logo yet. And while I agree that, like, Carbon is so early days that, like, you know, it's an experimental phase, that I do understand why people are like, where's the logo? Where's the logo?
它有一个棒极了的 logo，它把矩阵的概念融入其中。而且，是的，我觉得，你知道，这是一个...我看到，是不是在某个 subreddit 上，人们在抱怨和询问为什么 Carbon 没有，或者也许那是上次肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）的采访中提到的，Carbon 还没有 logo。虽然我同意 Carbon 还处于非常早期阶段，你知道，它还处于实验阶段，但我确实理解为什么人们会问：logo 在哪？logo 在哪？
Because I think logos are, logos are, are. They matter. Yeah, they, they matter. And they're, they are. Or maybe another way to put it is like sort of the branding of your, of your library, the, the, how you present it to the world of your software in general is, matters. Even if it's, even if it's not a consumer-facing thing, even if your audience is entirely other developers.
因为我认为 logo 是，logo 是，是。它们很重要。是的，它们，它们很重要。而且它们确实是。或者换一种说法，就像是你的库的品牌宣传，你向世界展示软件的方式，这很重要。即使它不是面向消费者的东西，即使你的受众完全是其他开发者。
It still matters. Yes, it matters. All right, we're going to skip around. We were supposed to do this first. I was in the process of turning off my background, and then we got distracted. As we frequently do. And while I'm doing this, to uh all of the listeners so
这依然很重要。是的，这很重要。好了，我们要跳过一些内容。我们本来应该先做这个的。我当时正在关闭背景，然后我们分心了。就像我们经常做的那样。当我在做这个的时候，对所有的听众来说
um let me turn this off i'll explain what the big red thing here is in a second although unfortunately zoom is zooming so it's this is kind of cutting off this red thing here but you'll still be able to see wait what zoom is oh it zooms in um i understand so episode part one of the of the interview with sean baxter i think statistically was has been our most successful episode ever and it would have been even more more successful if uh our audio hadn't been terrible so So in the future, we will make sure when interviewing guests, because I think using this Yeti for two people in a room, it basically created like a tin can effect. We, I mean, we did it when we were in San Diego,
嗯，让我把这个关掉，我等会儿会解释这里这个大红色的东西是什么，虽然不幸的是 Zoom 在缩放，所以这有点把这里这个红色的东西给切掉了，但你仍然能看到，等等，Zoom 是什么，哦，它放大了一点，我明白了。所以肖恩·巴克斯特采访的第一部分，从统计数据来看，可以说是我们有史以来最成功的一期节目，如果我们的音频不是那么糟糕的话，它本可以更加成功。所以未来我们在采访嘉宾时，因为我觉得在房间里两个人共用这一个雪人（Yeti）麦克风，它基本上产生了那种罐头音效。我们，我是说，我们在圣迭戈时也这么做过，
but we were both on either sides of a table. And so I think it wasn't as bad. For the listeners that were thinking, what happened to the audio quality? We know, we know. And we'll make sure next time we bring Sean on for hot takes that our audio is fixed. All right, now for episode 100,
但我们当时坐在桌子的两侧。所以我想情况没那么糟。对于那些一直在想“音频质量怎么了”的听众，我们知道，我们知道。我们下次请肖恩来聊犀利观点时，一定会确保音频修好。好了，至于第 100 期节目，
you must be thinking, all right, this is kind of disappointing. I've been listening for a hundred episodes and they just talked about programming languages and the value of branding. I think it's a little bit of a stretch to say that we've had 100 episodes where we've talked about programming languages
你一定在想，好吧，这有点令人失望。我听了一百期节目，他们居然只讨论了编程语言和品牌价值。我觉得说我们有 100 期节目都在谈论编程语言未免有点夸张了，
because I think at least 60% of the content has been us talking about Lululemon or Bubly or other random stuff. First of all, if you're a Bubly representative and you're listening, trying to figure out if you're a bubbly representative trying and you're listening trying to figure out if you should sponsor us don't worry about bryce's mispronunciation uh i know it's bubbly even though i like to say buble uh it's whatever bryce said bubble and did i say that we've been talking about program i meant to say that like for the first
因为我觉得至少 60% 的内容都是我们在聊露露乐蒙（Lululemon）或 Bubly 气泡水或其他乱七八糟的东西。首先，如果你是 Bubly 的代表，正在听这期节目，想看看你应不应该赞助我们，不用担心布莱斯的错误发音。我知道它是 Bubly，尽管我喜欢说 Buble，不管布莱斯刚才怎么说的吧，反正就是 Bubble。我是说我们一直在谈论编程，我的意思是，在前
15 minutes of this episode or 20 minutes or however long it's been we've been talking about programming language logos but here with us for episode 100 we have a generator of infinite bubbly carbonated water it's a soda stream here we go we're gonna do this live on the podcast this could make a mess because i'll be honest I don't really know how to use this thing. Have you used it before? I used it yesterday and water went everywhere. It is about three inches away from his microphone.
这期节目的 15 分钟或 20 分钟里，或者不管过去多久，我们一直在讨论编程语言的 logo。但在第 100 期节目中，和我们在一起的是一个无限苏打碳酸水的生成器，这是一个 SodaStream 机器，我们开始吧。我们要在这个播客里现场演示，这可能会弄得一团糟，因为老实说，我真的不知道怎么用这玩意儿。你以前用过吗？我昨天用过，水溅得到处都是。它离他的麦克风大概只有三英寸。
If this is the end of the episode, you know what happened. I think you're just supposed to poof it though. You're not supposed to hold it. That was the problem. I was just like, all right, we'll go like a beater. All right, here we go. You're supposed to give it like a couple poofs.
如果这是这期节目的结尾，你知道发生什么了。不过我想你只需要按几下就行了。你不应该一直按着。问题就在这。我当时就像是，好吧，我们就来按一下。好了，我们开始。你应该给它按个好几下。
Oh, yeah, it is spilling. It's making a mess. Man, why does it? Are you supposed to? Oh. And why does it, are you supposed to, ooh. Connor is pushing the button and some bubbles are going into the bottle. He's very gingerly just doing little squirts at a time. Now he is removing the bottle from the machine. There is water everywhere.
哦，是的，它在溢出来了。弄得一团糟。天哪，为什么会这样？你应该？哦。为什么它，你应该，噢。康纳正在按按钮，一些气泡正在进入瓶子里。他非常小心翼翼地一次只喷一点。现在他正在把瓶子从机器上拿下来。到处都是水。
It is a beautiful red color, this machine. I'm going to use my shirt to soak this up because I don't want to go get paper towels. There appears to be a lot of water on Connor's desk. I'm not even sure that Connor has paper towels in his apartment. I definitely do. I definitely do. But look what we have here. You didn't think we were just going to – so let me take a little sip, see.
这台机器的红色真漂亮。我要用我的衬衫来把水吸干，因为我不想去拿纸巾。康纳的桌子上似乎有很多水。我甚至不确定康纳的公寓里有没有纸巾。我绝对有。我绝对有。但看看我们有什么。你不会以为我们只是——所以让我喝一小口，看看。
Is this carbonated? Oh, my God. I did not do that enough. All right. Here we go again. Oh, shit. Okay. Water went everywhere now.
这有碳酸气吗？哦，天哪。我刚才按得还不够。好吧。我们再来一次。哦，操。好吧。水现在到处都是了。
Water whenever you are. I do need to go get paper towels. All right, Connor is now departing to grab some paper towels. Why is this so difficult? You still with us, Bryce? I am still here. All right, let's try it again. This is evolving into an actual disaster at this point. I think I got it.
水到处都是。我确实得去拿点纸巾了。好的，康纳现在离开去拿一些纸巾了。这为什么这么难？你还在听吗，布莱斯？我还在这里。好吧，我们再试一次。事情发展到这一步简直成了一场灾难。我想我搞定了。
I think I got it. I think I got it. I think I got it. I think I got it, folks. No, that sucks. All right, well. We could have had Sean Parent or some exciting guest on for episode 100. Instead, we chose this. I mean is this basically right and now what I have is I've got bubbly drops. Uh blackberry bubbly. I don't actually know how to use this. I assume you just put a couple drops in. All right and uh so now folks I'll figure out how to get this to work
我想我搞定了。我想我搞定了。我想我搞定了。各位，我想我搞定了。不，这太糟糕了。好吧，随它去吧。我们本可以请肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）或其他令人兴奋的嘉宾来参加第 100 期节目。相反，我们选了这个。我是说，基本上就是这样，现在我有的是 Bubly 果味滴剂。黑莓味的 Bubly。我其实不知道怎么用这个。我想你只要滴几滴就行了。好吧，各位，我会研究一下怎么弄这玩意儿，
in the future. Switch this up a little bit and and here's Connor's official review of SodaStream that he doesn't know how to use correctly. Pretty much garbage. Luckily, though, I also have a beer. Isn't it a little early for a beer? It is. I guess you ran this morning. It is 11.18 a.m.,
以后再说吧。稍微换个话题，这是康纳对 SodaStream 的官方评价，鉴于他根本不知道怎么正确使用它：简直就是垃圾。不过幸运的是，我也有一杯啤酒。喝啤酒是不是有点太早了？确实是。我想你今天早上刚跑完步。现在是上午 11 点 18 分，
but it is a celebratory beer, not just of our 100th episode, but it's technically our 101st episode, which zero indexing always irritates me for that. Oh, wait, so our 100th episode was with Sean.
但这是一杯庆祝的啤酒，不仅是为了庆祝我们的第 100 期节目，严格来说这是我们的第 101 期节目，零索引总是让我对此感到很烦恼。哦，等等，所以我们的第 100 期节目是和肖恩一起录的。
Yes. Okay, all right, it's okay. I mean, this is episode 100 though which is was it did we do an episode just for sean talked about moby dick we did yeah last episode was uh like that was episode 100 it was 50 minute 15 minutes of moby dick and then 15 minutes of uh listing off our favorite movies yeah one. One of the things that I really appreciate about Sean, and I think I can say this without having to worry about embarrassing him, because I'm pretty sure he doesn't regularly listen to the podcast,
对。好吧，没关系。我的意思是，这确实是第 100 期节目，不过我们是不是做过一期只为肖恩录的节目，聊了《白鲸记》？我们做过，对。上一期节目就像是那是第 100 期节目，有 15 分钟的《白鲸记》，然后有 15 分钟列举我们最喜欢的电影。是的。我对肖恩非常欣赏的一点，我想我可以不用担心会尴尬地说出来，因为我很确定他并不经常听这个播客，
but Sean's this prolific programmer who's created this really awesome visionary compiler. But he also has, you know, he's so cultured as well. You know, he finds time to do other things in his life as well. You know, he's this scholar of Moby Dick. You know, he appreciates good literature, good movies. And that's one of the things I really like about him. And the man knows how to find a good bar and seduce the, what's the word I'm looking for? Bartender?
但肖恩是一位多产的程序员，他创造了这个非常棒、富有远见的编译器。但他也，你知道的，他非常有文化修养。你知道，他总能在生活中抽出时间做其他事情。你知道他是《白鲸记》的学者。你知道，他欣赏好的文学作品、好的电影。这也是我很喜欢他的地方。而且这人知道怎么找一家好酒吧并勾引，我用的是什么词来着？调酒师？
The bartender. So we should clarify because it sounds bad when you say it like that, but really what he's trying to's not it's not like he's seducing female he's seducing bartenders in general regardless of gender and he's just trying to how would you describe it like win them over by for the the trade of bartending and and he um he wants to win over the hearts and minds yeah of the bartenders in his life yeah yeah so uh yeah it was good i mean i thoroughly enjoyed uh uh we'll have to have him back on at some point yeah but yes i didn't I didn't finish explaining.
调酒师。所以我们得澄清一下，因为你这么说听起来很糟糕，但实际上他试图做的是——这并不像他是在勾引女性，他在勾引所有的调酒师，不分性别，他只是想——你该怎么形容呢？就像是通过调酒这门手艺去赢得他们的好感，而且他，他，他想要赢得他生活中的调酒师的心智，对吧，对吧。所以，是的，这很好，我的意思是，我很享受，我们以后还得找个机会请他回来。不过，是的，我还没讲完。
It's a celebration of episode 100, but also I just ran the Toronto half marathon. Literally, like, finished it. What was your time? Just over an hour ago. It was pretty good. It wasn't as fast as I was hoping. It was, yeah, my legs got a bit tired in the middle,
这是对第 100 期节目的庆祝，但同时我也刚刚跑完了多伦多半程马拉松。字面意思上，刚刚跑完。你的成绩是多少？就在一个多小时前。挺不错的。没有我希望的那么快。是的，我的腿在中间跑得有点累了，
but it was a personal best, an hour, 17 minutes and 20-something seconds. So it's pretty good. We're going to go out and celebrate with the Run Club later on. And, yeah, what are we going to talk about for the last 10 minutes? So you're going to Austin. Yeah, I'm going to austin yeah and then um i'm going for for i'm going to this uh o3d con which is um a linux foundation conference for um an open source uh uh graphics and gaming and vr and uh digital twin uh engine um digital twin so? So this is not NVIDIA's? This is some other thing?
但这是一个个人最好成绩，1小时 17 分 20 多秒。所以相当不错。我们一会儿要出去和跑步俱乐部（Run Club）一起庆祝一下。然后，是的，最后 10 分钟我们要聊点什么？所以你要去奥斯汀。对，我要去奥斯汀，然后，嗯，我要去参加这个叫 o3d con 的会议，这是一个 Linux 基金会的会议，是为了一个开源的图形、游戏、VR 和数字孪生引擎，数字孪生。所以这不是英伟达（NVIDIA）的？这是别的什么东西吗？
No, no. I think it was I think it like started out of something from Amazon but it's an open source project and now it's run by the Linux Foundation.
不，不。我想它，我想它最初是从亚马逊的某个项目开始的，但它是一个开源项目，现在由 Linux 基金会运营。
So it's used for, you know, video games and like anything where you need to do a, create a 3D world of some sort or a simulation. Interesting. That sounds neat. Yeah. And so I'm going to give a talk about the three things that I'm most excited about that are coming in C++, not in C++23, but sort of beyond that. Ooh.
所以它用于，你知道的，电子游戏以及任何你需要制作某种 3D 世界或模拟的场景。听起来很有趣。是的。所以我要做一个演讲，讲讲 C++ 中我最期待的三件事情，不是 C++23 中的，而是超出这个范围的。噢。
Are we allowed a preview? Are we allowed a preview? Yeah. Yeah. Well, what would you think that my three things would be? Well, executors and centers and receivers didn't get in, so I assume that's one of the three. That is on the list.
我们能先睹为快吗？我们能提前透露一点吗？可以。好吧，你觉得我的三件事会是什么？嗯，执行器（executors）以及发送器（senders）和接收器（receivers）没能入选，所以我猜那是其中之一。那确实在名单上。
Yeah. That's the one of the three. That is on the list, yeah. That's the third of my three things. If it's going to be 3D graphics, I mean, I'm 50-50 on this, if this would be, whether this would be on your list. But reflection? Yeah, reflection. Because that's big for them, right? This talk was a talk that I'd made for another conference a while back. And so this was not three things that I picked specifically for this audience.
是的。那是三件事中的一件。那确实在名单上，是的。那是我的三件事中的第三件。如果这要涉及 3D 图形，我是说，对此我持一半一半的态度，不知道这会不会在你的名单上。但是反射（reflection）？对，反射。因为这对他们来说很重要，对吧？这个演讲是我不久前为另一个会议准备的。所以这并不是我专门为这个听众挑选的三件事。
It was just the three things for a general C++ audience. But yeah, reflection was the number one thing on the list. And then the third thing I would guess is probably not, but contracts? I don't know. No pattern matching. Oh, yeah, yeah. I keep forgetting that we don't know. No pattern matching. Oh, yeah, yeah. I keep forgetting that we don't have that yet. Yeah. So, yeah, so I talked a little bit about reflection
对于一般的C++受众来说，也就只有这三样东西。不过，对，反射是清单上的头号大事。然后第三个我猜大概不是，但契约算吗？我不知道。没有模式匹配。哦，对，对。我老是忘掉我们还不知道。没有模式匹配。哦，对，对。我老是忘掉我们现在还没有这个。所以，对，所以我稍微聊了一下反射，
and then about sort of things beyond what we'll get in the first set of reflection, which will just be the static reflection APIs, I think. But I talked a little bit about things like how you'll be able to do generative metaprogramming with reflection information. I don't even know if there's a proposal for this, but it's based on a slide I borrowed from Andre of showing how you would use some sort of template for construct at class scope to generate members of a class, like a wrapper class, using reflection. That's something that we don't have yet. We don't have some sort of template for or some sort of way to do that. But I think we'll probably get that once we, hopefully they're alongside the initial reflection mechanisms
然后聊了些超越第一批反射内容的东西，我想第一批反射内容大概就只有静态反射API吧。不过我稍微聊了一些诸如你将如何利用反射信息来进行生成式元编程之类的事情。我甚至不知道有没有针对这个的提案，但它是基于我从安德烈那里借来的一张幻灯片，展示了你如何利用某种类作用域的模板来构建类的成员，比如用反射来生成一个包装类。那是我们目前还没有的东西。我们没有某种模板或者某种方法来做到这一点。但我认为我们很可能在拥有了最初的反射机制之后就会得到它，希望它们能与最初的反射机制同时推出，
or as a slightly later feature, sort of like the metaclasses-esque stuff although i imagine that um i think we'll get a you know some of the building blocks one piece at a time not sort of the whole metaclasses thing um and then yeah and then pattern matching which i think is um uh gonna be a really transformative feature uh is that targeted for, because for a long time it was on C++23, and I haven't super paid attention, but from what I know, there's now two competing, there's the is-as one,
或者作为稍后一点的特性，有点类似于元类（metaclasses）风格的东西，虽然我想象，嗯，我觉得我们会得到，你知道的，一些积木式的特性，一步一步来，而不是那种完整的元类东西。然后，对，接下来就是模式匹配，我认为这是一个……嗯……将会是一个非常具有变革性的特性。这个是瞄准了……因为很长一段时间以来它都被列在C++23里，我虽然没怎么密切关注，但据我所知，现在有两个互相竞争的方案，一个是is-as方案，
and then there's the one from Michael Park and friends. Yeah, I don't entirely know that there's been, I don't know what the status of that is right now, and I don't know how much progress there's been the last year. But keep in mind, we're in the process of finishing up C++ 23. Yeah. So usually when we're in that last like three months of finishing up the release, we're really focused on that release. And then after that, we will start to focus on the next release. But there's actually sort of another thing that I don't think
另一个是迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park）及其同伴提出的方案。对，我不太清楚现在是否已经有了定论，我不知道目前它的进展状态如何，也不知道过去一年里取得了多少进展。但请记住，我们正处于敲定C++ 23的尾声阶段。对。所以通常当我们在进行发布前最后大约三个月收尾工作的时候，我们的主要精力都会高度集中在那个版本上。在那之后，我们才会开始把注意力转向下一个版本。但实际上还有另一件事，我觉得
I'm going to cover in the talk, but that I think maybe there's two things actually, but I'll focus on the one that I first had in mind, which is I would really like to see us take another look at language level tuple and variant, especially in the context of something like pattern matching. But, you know, even in the context of senders and receivers, because senders and receivers relies pretty heavily on tuples and variants because a sender can send multiple values, a tuple. Right. And a sender can also send um either a value an error or a you know a done signal um and so when you need to represent what things could a sender possibly send like if i want to say like i want a sender that if i want to constrain to say like i want a sender that sends an int um it's actually a little bit more complicated than that because like what if you want to say like i want a sender that sends either an int or sends me this type of error code.
我不会在演讲中讲到，但我认为——其实可能还有两件事，不过我会专注于我最初想到的那件，那就是我非常希望我们能重新审视语言级别的元组（tuple）和变体（variant），特别是在类似模式匹配这样的语境下。但是，你知道的，即使在发送者和接收者（senders and receivers）的语境下也是如此，因为发送者和接收者在很大程度上依赖于元组和变体，因为一个发送者可以发送多个值，也就是一个元组。没错。而且一个发送者还可以发送……嗯……要么是一个值、一个错误，或者是一个……你知道的……完成信号……诸如此类。所以当需要表示一个发送者可能发送什么东西时——比如如果我想说，我想找一个发送者，如果我想限定说我想要一个发送者发送一个int——其实这比那要复杂一点点，因为比如你想说，我想要一个发送者，它要么发送一个int，要么发送给我这种类型的错误码。
Then you're saying you want like a sender of variant of, you know, int and then the error code type. And you can end up in these cases where when you're working with some of the sender adapters, you might end up with variants of tuples of variants. And just over the years, I've become increasingly aware of how painful the library variant in tuple is. Well, there is a language variant proposal out there. Yeah. And a language tuple proposal. I was initially supposed to give a talk internally
那你就是在说你想要一个类似于由int和错误码类型构成的variant的发送者。你最终可能会遇到这样一些情况：当你使用某些发送者适配器时，你可能会得到由variant组成的tuple，而tuple又是由variant组成的。这些年来，我越来越深刻地意识到标准库中的variant和元组有多么痛苦。不过，外面确实有一个语言级别的variant提案。对。还有一个语言级别的元组提案。我本来应该在周五的时候在内部给一个研究小组做个演讲，
to a research group on Friday but then we ended up switching topics at the last second but it was it was a I had mentioned oh there's some talk I'm going to give in the future a couple weeks ago of like the five things that I think all languages should have some form of and uh on that list is basically um well actually i didn't technically include a language tuple but like destructuring and algebraic data types and a variant of which is one of them i just think are so like the fact that we got so far so many decades with just product types aka classes and only recently have variants and the choice type or enums showing up in languages like Rust. They've become idiomatic.
但后来我们在最后关头换了话题。不过，这是一个……我几周前曾提到过，未来我要做一个演讲，讲讲我认为所有语言都应该具备某种形式的五样东西，而在那个清单上基本上是……嗯……其实我技术上并没有把语言级元组包括进去，但像解构、代数数据类型，以及作为其中之一的variant，我只是觉得它们太……我们用了几十代的时间，竟然只靠积木类型（product types，也就是类），直到最近才在Rust等语言中看到variant和选择类型（choice types，即枚举）出现，这不是很说明问题吗？它们已经变得非常符合地道用法了。
It just seems so... How many times is there a list of options that are mutually exclusive where it's either this or that? And it's such a bread and butter thing that just pops up all over the place. And having that built into the language, I just think is such a huge win. And yeah, it is extremely painful using std variant.
这似乎太……有多少次，我们会遇到一组互斥的选项，要么是这个，要么是那个？这是一种如此基础的核心功能，在各处不断涌现。如果能把它直接内置到语言中，我认为将是一个巨大的胜利。而且，说实话，使用std::variant极其痛苦。
I mean, I think if we'd had a notion of language level tuples or variants the the advent of c++ or the advent of c would have drastically changed the patterns for how we write software yeah yeah um for for one like i think it would really change uh interface design um if we had both variant and tuple from the get-go, I think you would see far fewer output parameters. Right, yeah. Because why wouldn't you just return them? Obviously, if you're doing something sort of pass-by-pointer, if it's not value semantics, then yes,
我的意思是，我想如果我们从C++或C诞生之初就有了语言级元组或variant的概念，那么我们编写软件的模式将会发生颠覆性的改变。对，对……举个例子，我认为它会彻底改变……接口设计。如果我们从一开始就同时拥有variant和元组，我想你会看到少得多的输出参数。对，没错。因为你为什么不直接返回它们呢？显然，如果你在做某种按指针传递（pass-byoring）的操作，如果它不是值语义，那么是的，
you might need to have output parameters. Or if you want to give users control over whether the thing is returning the stack or whether it's just some memory location it's written to, you might still want that. But I think in a lot of cases, you would just have the far clearer sort of functional semantics where all of the inputs are just inputs, or all the function arguments are just inputs. And I think it also would have really changed how we do error handling. There's so many C-style libraries that just return an error code as their only return value. And oftentimes that pushes them into the output parameter style solely because
你可能仍然需要输出参数。或者如果你想让用户控制该对象是返回到栈上，还是写入到某个特定的内存位置，你可能依然会需要它。但我认为在许多情况下，你只需采用那种更加清晰的函数式语义，即所有的输入都仅仅是输入，或者所有的函数参数都仅仅是输入。而且我认为它也会彻底改变我们进行错误处理的方式。有那么多C风格的库，仅仅返回一个错误码作为它们唯一的返回值。而这往往迫使它们采用输出参数的风格，仅仅因为
the convention is that the return value is the error code. And it might have led us to more creative ways of returning errors than just error codes, which I think often become problematic for libraries because you end up with, I remember HPX, which is this parallel runtime I worked on for many years, we threw exceptions, but we had an error code mechanism under the hood, sort of similar to std error code. And so we had an enum of all the different error types that could be thrown. And I forget the name of the particular error code,
惯例规定返回值必须是错误码。这本可能会引导我们探索出比单纯的错误码更有创意的错误返回方式，而我认为错误码对库来说往往会变成棘手的问题，因为你会遇到——我记得HPX，这是我参与开发多年的一个并行运行时，我们抛出了异常，但在底层我们有一个错误码机制，有点类似于std::error_code。因此我们有一个枚举，包含了所有可能被抛出的不同错误类型。我忘了那个特定错误码的名字了，
but we had some vague one, like invalid input or something like that. And it was like 50% of the errors that could be produced by the whole code base was like invalid input. And if you got that one, you know, there might be a descriptive string telling you like a little bit more about what happened, but, um, uh, you know, it's, if you just leave the error code, you'd be like, what does this mean? Like, I don't know what this means. I got to go look it up in the doc. It doesn't tell me anything useful. And CUDA is also like that. But in CUDA, there's no way to encode a specific error code message.
但我们有一些比较模糊的错误码，比如“无效输入（invalid input）”之类的一类。整个代码库中可能有多达50%的错误都可以归结为“无效输入”。如果你碰巧遇到了这个错误，你知道的，可能还会有一串描述性的字符串告诉你更多关于发生的事情的细节，但是……嗯……你知道的，如果你只留下那个错误码，你就会想：这是什么意思？我根本不知道这是什么意思。我得去查文档。它根本没告诉我任何有用的信息。CUDA也是这样的。但在CUDA中，根本没有办法编码一个特定的错误码消息。
You just get the code out of the API. So if the API gives you back CUDA error and valid value, you just have to go look up you know what does that mean um and uh yeah that's that's just a little too vague for me probably all of my recent either python or c++ projects i use um cybrands expected which i think technically now gCC 11 point something or 13. I can't remember which one they're on, but like one of them actually ships with stood expected now and C plus plus 23. Like they already have that feature in,
你只能从API中拿到那个代码。所以如果API返回给你CUDA错误“无效值（invalid value）”，你只能去查阅文档才知道那到底是什么意思。而且……嗯……这对我的口味来说实在有点太模糊了。我最近所有的Python或C++项目，我都会使用……嗯……std::expected，我想现在GCC 11点几或者13版本里技术上已经有了。我记不清具体是哪个版本了，但其中一个版本现在确实在C++ 23中自带了std::expected。它们已经把这个特性放进去了，
but I haven't started using that version of the compiler. So I usually still use side brands, TL colon colon expected. And then Python has like an okay package, which is the equivalent of like the expected in c++ and like rust has you know built in or has it you know one of their standard libraries and it's yeah i mean i think even sean parent is not a believer he doesn't believe in um the expected type and thinks it just like pollutes all your code. But I, you know, for little small projects
但我还没开始使用那个版本的编译器。所以我通常仍然使用std::expected的作者（SBrauns）提供的TL::expected。然后Python也有一个不错的包，就相当于C++中的expected，而Rust也有内置的，或者在其标准库中提供了。这真的是……我的意思是，我觉得甚至肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）也不是个信徒，他不相信……嗯……expected类型，认为它只会污染你的所有代码。但是，你知道的，对于你在设计的小型项目
and games that you're designing, like where, you know, exceptions, you don't really need exceptions in my opinion. Like you've got some function that's trying to calculate something and it's either going to be like a list of, like you said, like an enum of, it's either this happened or this happened or this happened,
和游戏来说，你知道的，异常——依我看，你其实并不真的需要异常。比如你有一些函数正在尝试计算某些东西，它要么返回一个列表——就像你说的，一个枚举，比如发生了这个，或者发生了那个，或者发生了那个，
or you get the correct result and being able to just return some error message or the correct thing and then unwrap that where the call call site happens is just so phenomenally like useful and it's just easier for my brain to reason about it's more declarative in my opinion yeah that'll be exciting talk is that going to be recording online or uh i think it'll be recording and i think it'll be online. And I'm also doing a C++, ask the C++ committee question panel, but it's just me and Zach Lane.
要么你得到了正确的结果。能够直接返回某个错误消息或正确的结果，然后在调用处解包（unwrap），真的是好用到爆，而且在我的大脑里更容易进行逻辑推理，依我看它更具声明性。对，那将是一个令人兴奋的演讲，那个会在线录制还是……嗯……我想它会被录制下来，而且我想应该会在网上发布。我还要主持一个“向C++委员会提问”的小组问答环节，但只有我和扎克·莱恩（Zach Lane）。
Oh, that'll be fun. Is Zach in Austin? He works for Cadence, right? Yeah, he is. I was, there was another C++ committee member who was in Austin, but had since moved. But it'll be interesting because I've done Q&A panels with three before, never with two.
哦，那一定很有趣。扎克在奥斯汀吗？他为Cadence工作，对吧？是的，他在。我……之前还有另一个C++委员会成员在奥斯汀，但后来搬走了。不过这会很有趣，因为我以前和三个人一起做过问答小组，但从来没和两个人一起做过。
That'll be fun. To do it with Zach? I think it'll be fun, yeah. Zach's a party. Yeah, yeah, he's a real fun guy. He was – remember when we were in Prague and we were doing the recordings for the little vlog thing we ended up putting out and him and Eric Niebler recorded together. And then he went and told that whole story about where they went when they went to some museum.
和扎克一起做肯定很有趣。我觉得会很有趣，对。扎克是个聚会咖。对，对，他是个非常有趣的人。他曾——还记得我们在布拉格的时候，我们为最终发布的小视频博客（vlog）进行录制，他和埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）一起录制。然后他讲了那个关于他们去了某个博物馆的故事。
And then we had to cut all of it. And then basically all that ended up being in it was just the thing at the end. And that's why it's nice to bring a friend. That's like the only part of his like eight-minute story. I remember that. It was hilarious. You've got to put a link to that video in the show notes because our listeners may not have seen that. That was really a work of greatness that was produced in a very short time frame.
然后我们不得不把所有的内容都剪掉了。基本上最终保留在视频里的只有结尾的那部分。这就是带个朋友一起去的好处。那是他大约八分钟的故事中唯一保留下来的部分。我还记得那件事。太搞笑了。你必须在节目笔记中放那个视频的链接，因为我们的听众可能还没看过。那真的是在极短时间内制作出的一部杰作。
That was very impressive work on your part. I did none of it other than saying we should do this yeah i mean you were there for the helping interview and questions and stuff and uh i mean if i ever that was the last in-person c++ committee meeting it was indeed it was indeed um yeah it's ages ago it feels like i mean it was a long time ago but yeah it was it was 2019 2020 it was february right yeah you're right it was literally like a month i think actually i can't remember it was like right before code i was gonna say like i can't remember the first time i heard about i think like i might have heard we might have heard there were news stories about like oh
你做的那项工作非常令人印象深刻。除了说“我们应该这么做”之外，我什么也没做。对，我的意思是，你在那里帮忙采访和提问之类的工作，而且……我的意思是，如果我没记错的话，那是最后一次线下的C++委员会会议。确实是的，确实是的。嗯……感觉是很久以前的事了。我的意思是，那确实是很久以前了，但对，那是2019年，2020年2月，对吧？对，你说的没错，实际上就在……我想大概是一个月前，其实我记不清了，大概就在疫情爆发前夕。我刚想说，我不记得我第一次听说它的时间了，我想我可能听说过，我们可能听到过一些新闻报道，比如哦，
there's this new yeah yeah flu outbreak in China at that point. In China, yeah. But like there was no. Although, spoiler alert, it wasn't just in China. Yeah. Anyways, do you got to go? I think I probably should go because I got to pack. pack and my flight's not actually until this evening but um i i have to go to uh the the global entry office at the jfk airport before my it's a whole long story um uh i applied to renew
当时中国出现了这种新的……嗯……流感爆发。在中国，对。但当时还没有。虽然，剧透一下，不仅仅在中国。不管怎样，你得走了吗？我想我大概真的得走了，因为我还得收拾行李。打包行李，我的航班其实要到今天晚上才起飞，但……嗯……我得去……在去机场前先去JFK机场的Global Entry（全球入境计划）办公室，这说来话长……嗯……我申请续签
my global entry and they you can at the same time you can apply to do this APAC business traveler card, which lets you travel to a certain set of Asian and Pacific Island countries for business travel without filling out a visa. And I was like, oh, sure. I'll just add this on. This is easy. I'm planning to go to Japan again later this year for business travel. So I'll just go do this. And there's this great, it used to be you had to schedule a global entry interview at a location and then you had to like go to the country and do customs. So if you just happen to be flying internationally and coming back, instead of having to go to the airport specifically to do your interview,
我的Global Entry，你同时还可以申请办理APAC（亚太）商务旅行卡，这张卡能让你无需填写签证即可因商务目的前往特定的一组亚洲和太平洋岛国。当时我想，哦，当然，我顺便把这个加上，这很简单。我计划今年晚些时候因商务再次去日本，所以我就去办这个。有一个很棒的规定——以前你必须预约某个地点的Global Entry面试，然后你必须去那个国家办理海关手续。所以，如果你刚好要进行国际飞行并准备回国，你就不需要专门为了面试跑一趟机场，
you can just do it on your way back through customs. So I had a bunch of international flights this summer. The first time I tried to go to do the interview when I returned through customs, they're like, it's too late in the day. They're closed. You're going to have to try again another day. Um, and then the second time was when I was coming back from Israel and, uh, that time our flight got in at five and we had to wait
你可以在回程过海关的时候顺便完成面试。所以今年夏天我有一堆国际航班。我第一次试图在通过海关回国时去参加面试，他们却说：时间太晚了，已经关门了。你得改天再来试试。嗯，第二次是我从以色列回来的时候，嗯，那次我们的航班在5点到达，我们不得不在
at the gate for an hour because customs wasn't open yet. So I'm like, all right. Yeah. 5.00 AM. So I was like, great. At least like custom isn't open yet, but at least they're going to like, they can't say that, that it's too late to do the interview because first thing in the morning and they go and they do the interview for me at the uh the the customs checkpoint and then like as she's getting to the end she's like you know what i'm really sorry but your your application it's combined with this apac card thing and for that thing you got a sign and we don't have the signature pad here. You're going to have to go over to the other terminal to complete the interview. And I'm like, I just can't do it right now because I've just been on a plane for 14 hours.
登机口等了一个小时，因为海关还没开门。所以我当时想，好吧。对，早上5点。所以我当时想，太好了。至少……海关虽然还没开门，但至少他们……他们不能说时间太晚没法面试了，因为这是清晨的第一件事，然后他们去海关检查站帮我做了面试……就在她快要结束的时候，她说：“你知道吗，真的很抱歉，但你的申请是和这个APAC卡绑定在一起的，为了那个卡你需要签名，我们这里没有电子签名板。你得去另一个航站楼完成面试。”当时我就想，我现在根本做不到，因为我刚刚在飞机上坐了14个小时。
Hard no. And I also need to go home and repack because I need to be on another plane in 24 hours. And so now I'm going back a third time. But hopefully. Third time's a charm. Third time's a charm. Third time's a charm. Yeah. We will.
坚决拒绝。而且我还需要回家重新打包行李，因为我需要在24小时内赶上另一架飞机。所以现在我要去第三次。不过希望……事不过三。事不过三。事不过三。对。我们会……
So when are we going to, you're going to be on the road. So are we going to be recording on the road or we'll find out? Well, next week I'm going to be in Austin and I don't think that'll be a good time to record. But the weekend after that. You'll be back in New York for a bit? Yeah. Okay.
那我们什么时候……你要在路上奔波。所以我们是在路上录制，还是到时候再看？嗯，下周我要去奥斯汀，我觉得那不是录音的好时机。但再接下来的那个周末……你会回纽约待一会儿？对。好吧。
For a week, which is a bit by my new definition and then we have to record a lot because I'm going to be in Hawaii for a week and then Japan for two weeks okay okay we'll figure that out well we'll finish this episode 100 to the listener
待一周，按我的新定义这算是一会儿了，然后我们就得大量录音，因为我要去夏威夷待一周，然后去日本待两周。好吧，好吧，我们会搞定的。好了，我们要结束这一期节目了，致听众朋友们，
because I think what is it and I want to just say to all of the listeners or to the listener I heard on Reddit someone said that they find it weird hearing listener because they know that there's multiple people out there.
因为我想——我想对所有的听众，或者说对这位听众说——我在Reddit上听到有人说，他们觉得听到“听众”（单数形式listener）觉得很奇怪，因为他们知道外面有很多听众。
They're about to hear it again. Dear listener, I want to say sincerely, thank you for listening to this podcast. You know, whenever I go to a conference these days, I tend to have a couple of people come up and tell me that they've listened to the podcast and how much they enjoy it and that they feel like they're getting to know the two of us through the podcast.
他们马上又要听到了。亲爱的听众朋友，我想由衷地对你们说，谢谢你们收听这个播客。你知道的，这些天每当我参加会议时，往往都会有几个人走过来告诉我，他们听了这个播客，有多么喜欢它，并且觉得通过播客他们开始真正了解我们两个了。
And that really warms my heart. I think that's sort of what we were going for, for you to feel like you're in the room with us, just chatting amongst friends. And I hope that you've learned something. And I'd like to think that we're getting better at this. And I hope that you'll continue listening because I think we've got a lot of great content still to come. The chaos continues.
这真的温暖了我的心。我想这正是我们一直以来所追求的，让你觉得仿佛和我们共处一室，就像朋友之间在随意聊天。我希望你有所收获。我也想认为我们在做这件事上越来越熟练了。我希望你能继续收听，因为我觉得我们还有很多精彩的内容要呈现。混乱仍在继续。
I can't remember what that quote was. Chaos with sprinkles of information. I think that was what it was. That's still, or a discussion with Sean. If we had a billboard, if we had a billboard, that would be the quote, your quote. Chaos with sprinkles of information. Yeah, and I'll say, I think we do,
我不记得那句名言是什么了。充满零星信息的混乱。我想大概是这个吧。那依然是……或者说是与肖恩的讨论。如果我们有一个广告牌，如果我们有一个广告牌，那就是这句话，你的那句话。充满零星信息的混乱。对，我要说，我觉得我们确实……
I think 50 episodes ago at episode 50, I had this little bit where I say, I don't like plugging for, you know, it irritates me to no end when other podcasts say, give us a five-star rating. And I was like, it'd be one thing to ask for a rating, but why are you asking just for five? Anyways, but once every 50 episodes, we do do our little plugs. Feel free to read.
我想在50集之前，也就是第50集的时候，我有一个小片段，我说过，我不喜欢做硬广，你知道的，每当别的播客说“给我们五星好评吧”时，我都烦透了。当时我说，请求评分是一回事，但你们为什么只要求五星呢？不管怎样，每隔50集，我们确实会做一点小小的自我宣传。欢迎评分。
I mean, we already get like people retweet and stuff, but if there is one episode you want to retweet, you know, retweet it. If you want to leave a review of however many stars, you know, or I don't even know how reviews work. I don't think I've ever left a review. But feel free to share with a friend. And yeah, more stuff to come over the next hundred. It also warms my heart.
我的意思是，我们已经有很多人转发之类的了，但如果真的有一集你想转发，你知道的，就转发它吧。如果你想留下几星的评价，你知道的，或者我甚至不知道评价是怎么运作的。我想我从来没留下过评价。但请随时与朋友分享。是的，接下来的100集还会有更多内容。这也温暖了我的心。
And maybe tweet at us what you want to see in the next hundred episodes. Yeah, yeah. Twitter's the best way to request stuff. But if you don't have Twitter, you can always go to github email does the podcast have an email i mean we do but i already have i have something new i have six email accounts and i like email is not the best way to get a hold of and i don't know definitely of me i'm not sure about you but um like twitter and github are better like someone opened an issue once and i made a topic request or like a um had some feedback and like
也许可以在推特上@我们，告诉你想在接下来的100子里看到什么。对，对。推特是提出请求的最佳途径。但如果你没有推特，你总是可以去GitHub……电子邮件呢？这个播客有邮箱吗？我的意思是，我们有，但我已经有了……我有新情况，我有六个电子邮件账号，而且我觉得电子邮件并不是联系我们的最佳方式。我不知道，至少对我是这样，我不确定你是不是也这么觉得，但是……像推特和GitHub会更好。比如有人曾在GitHub上提过一个issue，提出了一个话题请求或者……嗯……提出了一些反馈，然后……
yeah well definitely i i have to interact with the github every week we love github yeah because of the website um anyways thanks for listening uh i'll try and figure out how to work this soda stream thing and give you a better review next time but uh my review so far is i don't know i don't know how it works i you know i've tried the soda stream thing i i don't like the taste i've tried it before yeah it's not the same even if you do get it to work yeah yeah but but maybe you will yeah maybe you will all right all right thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对，绝对的，我每周都得跟GitHub打交道。我们爱GitHub。对，因为网站的原因……不管怎样，谢谢收听。我得设法研究一下这个苏打水机（soda stream）怎么用，下次给你一个更好的评价。不过我目前的评价是——我不知道，我不知道它是怎么运作的。我，你知道的，我试过那个苏打水机，我不太喜欢那个味道。我以前试过。对，味道不一样，即使你能把它弄成功运转起来。对，对。但也许你会吧。对，也许你会的。好啦，好啦，谢谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。